CCSD students are out on spring break
and for many that means they're not
getting breakfast and lunch that many
rely on in the schools to provide for
free our Lorna Grady joining us live
from Three Square at Pecos and Craig
Road with more on how the food bank is
ramping up its Outreach and also which
is so important how you at home can help
Lauren good morning
good morning yes there are a few
different options to get involved here
of course number one is going to the
website and scheduling time to volunteer
like right here at this campus right
here to pack those food meals that we're
talking about then there's also monetary
donations they're starting their batch
program for bagged childhood Hungary
next month during that time your day
Nations go further where one dollar
usually equals three meals it'll equal
six
ask for food options right now there's
their grocery pantries and then the kids
Cafe meals which are fresh meals for
teens and kids available for pickup at
local libraries the interim CEO tells me
that their three Square was not impacted
by CCSD not doing their grab-and-go
meals
they know that the food bank has our out
of school meal programs and our pantries
that families can go to on a regular
basis and so we're just kind of coming
back to the way that things have been
for for the almost 15 years that the
food bank has been in place
and you can find a library and food
distribution site on their website or of
course call the number on your screen
there for more information and to find
one near you now don't go anywhere
coming up more on how three square is
reaching those hungry children for now
live in North Las Vegas Lauren Negrete 8
News Now